let's say you reach out to some
businesses things that you like or enjoy
or feel like you have some specialized
knowledge in you find out that there's a
business that's doing 250 000 a year in
profit let's say you've got fifty
thousand dollars six hundred twenty five
thousand dollars you might pay for
businesses doing 250 000 a year in
profit when you would go to quote talk
to this business once you've agreed on
the price you negotiate down whatever
and then you say I need you to seller
finance three quarters of the deal what
you have remaining which would be like
in this instance 200 000 then you get a
note from the bank right or SBA loan
which you have a 200 000 loan for it and
you put your fifty thousand dollars down
the guy who's selling the business he
sells for 625 but he's only getting 200
000 up front you're only putting 50 of
that 200 and you're taking a loan for
the rest of it you've now acquired this
business that makes 250 000 a year so
you upgraded your income from 60 to 250
000 and if you compare that to what it
would cost you to start your own
business in terms of investment and like
existing book of business all the
knickknacks you have to buy that you
don't even think of it's actually pretty
decent deal